president joe biden said on tuesday
united states has enough covet funding
to get through at least this year but it
needs more money to plan for the next
pandemic we need more money to plan for
the next pandemic there's going to be
another pandemic we have to think ahead
biden said in remarks at the white house
to mark availability of vaccines for
young children which he said we are the
first country
in the world to have vaccines for kids
under the age of six months which he
celebrated and the commentary if you
read it it's actually
95 of people who commented on it was
negative but
are you reading into this comment or is
it just no we do need to prepare for the
next first of all how does he know we're
going to have another pandemic number
one number two i'm not
one who believes that the 19 vaccination
is necessarily safe nor effective but i
also believe that if you decide you want
to take it that's fine that's up to you
nobody should be required to take it i
believe in health freedom but i also
wonder whether there is a political
motivation in other words if you wanted
to say for example that going to the
polls was too dangerous because of a
pandemic and that all voting should be
done by mail-in ballot i think that's an
open invitation for voter fraud
good point
any thoughts on your end or no no you
know
the one that i do uh have a comment on
because both of you have used the term a
couple of times of giving money to
ukraine i i take a slightly different uh
ulterior motive for this and that comes
because of my background
russia second only to china
is a problem that we have had since 1917
and we will continue to have as long as
they're in power
and if you look at history
afghanistan war we helping the afghanis
and i know that with 2020 hindsight we
go gee we should have taken the missiles
back before we left
but
the ukraine can be the downfall
of what the soviet union is trying to
become
because when the russian body bags start
going back home
and let me tell you something one the
the u.s has been helping the ukraine's
iranians since
2015. they did not learn how to fight
and how to run intelligence networks in
the last three months
because there has been a
big shift from fighting wars to taking
steps to prevent wars
and the only way you can do that is
working with individuals in countries
that are allies
fortifying them and if there's an issue
let them fight that fight and you
support it but i i am all for for uh
keeping ukraine as that thorn in the
side of the russians besides the
humanitarian part and the atrocities are
being committed this is where we're
going to have to disagree
we signed a treaty in 1994 promising not
to have
uh ukraine join nato which is defined as
putting missiles aimed at russia uh in
nato we're now seeking to do that this
is not different than 1962 when the
russians put missiles in cuba and
president kennedy objected
and that was resolved thank god
diplomatically uh we do have bio weapons
labs uh in ukraine the silos are
actually built we haven't just dropped
the missiles in i think this could have
been resolved diplomatically had
ukrainians not agreed to join nato which
is defined as putting western missiles
in their country uh the idea that putin
who's not a good guy i want to be very
clear i mean my family were rushing down
mowed down by russian tanks in budapest
i have no truck for the russians uh he's
a thug
but at the same time the idea that he
just wants to occupy ukraine he can't
even afford that his economy is a basket
case so uh this is going to be a costly
war for him
but i think it could have been resolved
short of the carnage we see today
i don't disagree with that but the thing
that that ship has sailed we are at war
and if you're going to get any silver
lining out of this is let's really
button that up you know if the argument
that putin uses about ukraine being a
threat to them
well why are we doing something against
cuba
cuba is the the cancer of latin america
nicaragua venezuela colombia now
all these are are funded and influenced
and led there are more intel officers
from the cuban service
in those kind of countries
propping them up
didn't didn't colombia just get the
first socialist uh
democratic president which is their name
they're the next venezuelan he was
actually the uh a former senior
uh terrorist
part of the gorilla camp he was one of
the commanders of guerrilla camps but
you have to you have to wonder why the
us senate
and the one hand votes to give 40
million dollars in aid mostly military
lethal aids supposedly to ukraine but
then they vote down a motion to have an
inspector general track where that
money's going why wouldn't you want to
know where that money's going
it makes no sense to me
yes somebody just commented inception
child said
uh uh what will it take to put putin on
a terrorist list like biden like bin
laden was
or is he a terrorist only if he attacks
america so do you see
putin as somebody that should be on that
list or no he shouldn't be on that list
well you know he
he should for the different reasons but
you got to understand that what why are
we surprised at what putin is doing the
kind of person he is
he's not the anomaly in in in russian
and soviet government
if you go back to stalin and khrushchev
and everybody in between the majority of
those the leaders of soviet union and
now russia
are of that criminal bent you know they
have that mentality uh
uh the oligarchs that you know you've
got a hundred billionaires in russia
that are bleeding money
uh those things all these things made
you know bad for for russia
but he should that that that would be
another nail on his coffin declaring him
that because he is
he is responsible for the acts that the
military is committing in ukraine
would he be uh held accountable for war
crimes is that what you're saying
absolutely let me ask you to follow up
on that rick you basically have said
that russians and communists are
expansionists right and you followed up
and you said
um you know regarding putin's goals and
i want to ask you about putin's goals
you said that there a terminology i used
to use was creeping normalcy which is
basically you take a piece you wait for
a little bit
and then um you know kind of wait for
things to simmer down again and then
boom you attack again
so what do you think putin's goals are
he said it when he first took power i
would reconstitute
the soviet union to his previous glory
um
that's a clue right there how do you
create the soviet union again
you take over romania you take over
georgia you attack
you know take over the ukraine they are
inspectionistic
i don't think the cha the the russians
are creeping normalcy types
they're they're too blunt they're too
blunt with edge
koreans and asian
chinese are extremely good at that
that creeping normalcy and
where whereas we have barely three year
plans because of the fourth year the
president has to start focusing on the
re-election
the chinese or the russians don't have
that problem they can have a 50-year
plan a 100-year plan and you tweak it
according to what it is but the the end
goal is still the same
our end goal as america should be to
remain a republic
their goal is to world domination so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here